a few years ago I came across these
commercially available EEG headsets and
neuro Scalia sees as part of my company
that I was running at the time we
started experimenting with different
games and different things to do with
them but the main thing that we started
doing is like taking edits taking video
edits and then dropping him and a
program that would allow the viewer it
cut basically we're using like just
stuff off the cutting room floor really
and that's one that was a different way
of making a film as I usually do usually
like you script a new storyboard
egregious and that's one that was made
specifically with the interactivity of
the film and mains we had to do like
four different treatments from the
script and then also in editing I
usually you take the viewer on and
journey and edit and you choose very
succinctly and quaint what they see when
you see it and that's the creativity
that you would put in the Edit gets
passed often if your housing wasn't a
technical person your heads and
electrical signals from your brain and
also from your skin it gets filtered out
and sent via bluetooth and they've got a
Python program here
so that's live data now it's basically
yeah it's just getting like handy just
files at the minute
so as a piston on the signal quality
should drop to zero and that means I've
got a good connection with the deer
coming out so you can see in the
background the films playing as a blank
it's cutting and as you can see it
blends into two layers that's my
attention going from a high tool you see
if I blank to see this blank coming up
when I press play at fires off for
videos at once they're all playing and
think and then when I blink at jerzees a
set of two videos to play and then when
it's playing those two values the
attention is changing the blend or the
blend in between those two videos with a
blanket will jump to the other two
videos and then so cut blending between
those at the same time meditation is
controlling the mechs off the music so
the higher my meditation
level the more levels of the music so
data is coming from the headset via
bluetooth to the computer then our
Python program is pecking that data up
send the via OSC open sound control and
to max/msp which is a program LIRS years
to call it's a visual programming
language it looks a lot like this so the
thing comes them hears from the headset
is receiving the blank the attention of
meditation it's coming down there to on
a blank to cut between scenes and then
over here the the meditation has been
scaled to the four audio levels so we
can see there's like someone meditations
about 50% here that would be what's
going up about you just like add these
patch cars together so there's there's
my meditation point for it's between
zero and one so I've got that number I
spot this number here so you can see
it's m35 which is ren right here and
it's going up 66 you find some people
are more in control there binds and
others yeah totally and like those had a
few people who are do like meditation in
the morning it really able to control
like the meditation aspect offer most
people can't control that at all and the
biggest differences of people how people
want to control the film some people
want to experience a film what some
people want to control it and a few Grif
experiences were there was like one
person who just wanted to see their
feedback and they made this crazy film
that just really hurt other people's
heads so this is initially designed as
our a one-person experience I though
initially we had a lot with ten and you
went in and just watched about yourself
and when we took on turn
we felt we found that and people would
have a little bit